alright that was um a there was B to
find the vertex I have um some traces
here right there are two things I can do
before I do them what is the vertex
again what are we actually trying to
find
yeah very good it's where that's a very
sophisticated way of saying it
it's where the parabola turns around
another way of saying it simple way is
just where's the bottom point right
where's the bottom
this one's facing up so at the bottom if
it were facing down I'd want the top
right but they're the same point how do
I go I find you one of the two ways so
what does this anything yes tell you
okay
find the widest it I am going to find
the y-intercept the reason why I want
the y-intercept is because I can see I'm
heading somewhere in fact all of these
questions are heading here right but
y-intercept I can read it really simply
off how do I read the one set off this
equation yeah it's just this low volume
right just that guy there so y equals
negative seven is the Y I'll file that
away from laid up unfortunately though
it doesn't end up helping me all that
much to find the vertex this guy okay so
first thing I can do one method is I can
say look can you see that the vertex is
in line with the middle of the parabola
that one that axis of symmetry right and
from the quadratic formula we saw that's
where the axis of symmetry is right so I
can get this value
that'll give me an x value and I can pop
it in what is - B in this case on this
quadratic it's going to be positive 5 do
you see the double a - yeah so 502 a in
this case will be 4 okay there's an x
value and I popped that back into what
am I pop it into to get a Y value yeah
the original equation a bit try to be as
specific as you can to that lots of
equations flying around I want that one
okay so I'm going to go ahead and let's
see so I've got 2 5
or squared five times five four - seven
okay now you can machine this out if you
like like I'm about to do because I
don't have a calculator in my hand but
you probably do you have a calculator in
your hand so you can tell me whether I
get this right or not okay
two times twenty-five over sixteen to
2500
what's this gonna be that's 25 on 8 it
everything's in eights what's that in 8
that's 58 right what's that in eights
and I think it's 56 8 that's a lot of
eights
okay let's see 25 minus 50 is minus 25
takeaway 56 I think I'm getting that is
someone gonna tell you about a writer oh
yeah no wait I really do that in my head
fast up in anyone now did I do something
where where where where where which way
did I yeah am I right or not someone can
someone punches in and tell me if it's
that sound that I was right oh wow
that's amazing
can I get the 10 effect all the time
yeah No
yeah okay please tell me what I did get
as a fraction a/b of course you could
cause it yeah of course you wouldn't
wait what I do Oh I subtracted yeah of
course I know what I do all right there
you go yeah now before I finish and I'm
going to make sure this now even though
I didn't say why before why did I write
this is three and a half right Rondon
702 y is three and a half actually more
useful to me yeah good yeah yeah yeah
when I am I have to graph this right you
can see my mind is always on where is
this all heading like I'm looking
randomly doing this if I want to graph I
wouldn't know how big numbers are in
relation to each other now I have no
idea how seven over two and most anyone
over eight how they fit in terms of
scale right but three and a half and
minus ten and an eighth those I do know
like whole numbers and their little
frankly I can work with this okay all
right almost done
what do I do with this I haven't
answered the question yet I've done a
lot of work but I haven't answered the
question what is the question find the
vertex thank you so what I do is I just
take these two pieces of information you
see it's important not just to be able
to crunch numbers but to know what those
crunched numbers mean right so they're
the coordinates of my vertex I'm just
gonna - Anthony okay now I'm ready
thanks Eric I are you know what the
y-intercept is we've found the x
intercepts up in poppy poppy okay so
let's graph this thing
a cave I've got latest one if that's -
one I'm gonna go one two three
and where was my other thing - seven
okay are you ready to go do you remember
what we were talking about was kind of
like you're piecing together the clues
of all the crews I need as it happens
I'm actually going extra clues but this
is all I need now this vertex I'm going
to draw a horizontal line in do you
remember why I have a horizontal line
there yeah so it's not pointy at the
bottom and because it's going to come
down gently slow down and then lift back
off okay so that's what I'm gonna try
and draw something like this yes this
like here well okay I suppose the answer
is No however if you draw it properly
you will end up getting a little
horizontal part there anyway like it
does have to come down gently slow down
be horizontal forever so slightly a
small moment and then lift back up so if
you do it before I do it after are you
gonna get the same features yeah that's
exactly right it's kind of like a
ticklish trust me
I've I've drawn hundreds and thousands
of problems in their life and I've found
this to be useful so if it's not useful
to you just did you but I see a lot of
students get this part wrong and they
get their vertex wrong okay so one two
three four points anything else I should
put on this thing
yeah I should maybe label the thing 2x
squared there we go and I'm hurting you
happy